in all of life there should be a meaning
and intention to your actions and I
think our relationship with technology
has really missed that Mark
um so we are really trying to introduce
that into people's worlds and for young
people who've never known what that is I
think we are really you know helping
change their behavior by just adding an
ounce of intention
into what they're doing
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan we
are still at the transformative
technology conference we have moved
locations to a different location on
site still which is cool it's cool it's
nice to switch up the Ambiance every
once in a while we have Atlanta Harvey
joining us now on the show thank you
very much for coming on yes
and from flipped and you co-founded that
okay cool so co-founder of flipped and
doing uh helping the Next Generation
with the relationship with technology
which I'm really excited to talk to you
about and maybe before we get to there
just give us the quick bit on who you
are how do you even get into this space
yeah so I am the co-founder and CMO a
flipped
um and it all started a few years ago
when my co-founder who's actually my my
partner and we've been together for
eight years
um but a few years ago he gave his
youngest brother his first smartphone
um and just noticed how quickly his
relationship uh their relationship
actually was impacted by technology in
his life and so Christian thought is
there a way that instead of Technology
enabling these bad behaviors could we
shape behavior in a positive way with
technology and at the same time I was
finishing up my degree in school
marketing and Communications a business
degree at Ryerson University in Toronto
and meanwhile I was actually serving at
a restaurant and over that same time
period this was around 2014 so it was
when Snapchat and Instagram and all of
those things were really becoming
a lot more mainstream and it was still
fairly early days
but just noticing how that was impacting
people in a public space yeah
um and it was I had been working at that
place for about four years so it to me
also the behavior had shifted so
dramatically in a really short amount of
time yeah people just not interacting
face to face anymore not interacting
with me as their server and
um so we had those two pivotal moments
in our own lives and decided how about
we build technology
that helped solve this problem and
that's what we've been doing nice that
is a very cool story because I think we
don't think too much about the those
moments in society where technology is
introduced and societal Dynamics shift
on a global scale and the example of
Christian your partner
having his younger brother get up get a
phone a smartphone that is that is
insane because as soon as you pass it
over it's like the it just it just takes
over and then yeah the behavior and the
family changes and like you were seeing
as well when people go out and are not
engaging with each other engaging more
with their devices
there's a lot of nuance to it because
there are times that that may be the
subject that is being talked about like
somebody is saying something that maybe
you've heard before or you're not
interested in that specific conversation
that maybe you want to browse the
internet to learn something else there's
a lot of nuance to it it's tough to
unpack in binary conversation but
um okay so now that you in 2000 that was
2014's when flip became online or when
did it come online yeah that was like
early days for ideation that we launched
in 2016.
um and
what we initially thought we were
building was actually a parental control
application which would help parents
manage their kids screen time
um which funny enough has now become a
bit more on Trend but earlier uh we
weren't really attracting a lot of
parents to the platform but what we did
notice is that where there were a lot of
young people gravitating towards it for
self-regulation self-regulation so we
thought hey this is interesting it's not
a control experience it's a
self-regulated and self-motivated
experience and so that's what where we
shifted and moved towards and we've
actually now gone into schools trying to
help students who are otherwise unaware
of their attention deficiency and
inability to
maintain their attention and focus and
helping them with flipped yeah so tell
me about the self-regulation aspect to
things so give me the high level
overview of is available on like Android
and iOS is that the idea yeah so flipped
is available Android and iOS and has
been yeah since 2016. cool
um
how it works is that it adds like a
layer of friction when you're using your
device so it's kind of like a screen
saver for those of us that remember what
those are
that
stays on your phone and it prevents you
from leaving or it adds a level of
friction and makes you think twice about
leaving that experience and then it
tracks those moments so if you haven't
spent time on your phone and you've been
tracking it with flips then you it's
it's like a productivity and a focus
tracker that you can measure your
progress over time so we've gamified
that experience we have day streaks we
have leaderboards so people bring their
own friends and create little
communities where they're enjoying time
well spent together
and then they also can tag these moments
so if you're using it to study one day
or using it to read or spend time with
family then you can see a graph of all
of the ways you've been spending your
time away from technology
all right we got a little demo for
everyone we're gonna show you the demo
on on here so as you as you open up
flipped you're shown don't just be there
be present and then you go begin
and then you log in so I'm going to log
in with Facebook it's quite easy to get
through things
all they get is your name profile
picture and email address see they're
not asking you for everything
only asking for what they need
hello Alan
my personal stats okay welcome to
flipped
that's a message from me
oh it is a message from you there she is
at the top
I'm in two places at once everybody Tech
life balance is important
which is why we're here to help you
achieve it with flipped you'll be more
present engaged and focused when it
matters most write a short blog post
explaining all you need to know about
getting started
we wrote One Tap the image below to
check it out science behind flipped
cool
so then
so then here I see you know here's the
the home screen allowed my personal
stats total sessions minutes
today day streak so mindful moments my
day study sleep work interesting so if I
click work
for four hours what happens
so it'll be it'll begin a Time session
yep that just started four hours long
um if you want to end it early then it
will it will Mark you as uh whatever you
are successful up to that point so if
you used it for 10 minutes you would
still achieve 10 minutes
um so this is not allowing any
notifications to show up uh no you you
still get notifications
tracking your productivity uh whether or
not you were using that your phone so if
you leave that screen then the session
ends oh interesting so you basically you
can close your screen and set your phone
aside
oh you're giving up exiting the screen
will end your flip session early
interesting oh shoot you only completed
37 you'll do better next time
interesting
interesting and there's a streak counter
how many minutes today what are the
minutes about how long I did what for
um how many minutes I did these at
mindful moments for yeah yeah and you'll
see the 180 number yeah yeah so like
Fitbit made 10 000 steps uh a benchmark
for people to hit a daily goal
um we looked into our users and and
recognized that some of our most active
daily habitual users were achieving
three hours a day so we wanted to drive
more people to hit that and we thought
well three hours kind of sounds like a
really big number and 180 is a bit
easier it also rolls off the tongue
there's also the idea of a 180 like
you're giving yourself another
transformation so uh we launched that as
a marketing campaign a couple of months
ago and it's been really successful nice
nice flip off for a bit today unlocked
okay so so then full lock mode hide my
apps and turn off notifications yeah
okay so if I click select for five
minutes that one you have to go through
um an add-on you're about to be fully
locked out okay there's an add-on yeah
there's a there's an additional thing
you have to install to usage data usage
access to
got it so then you select those things
as like not allowed right or you would
select your uh as allowed interesting
and then so as I keep putting on their
sounds happy sound oh premium required
okay so that's where you get the first
one you should be able to listen to
campfire
okay let me go to campfire
campfire okay yeah since so
this is what campfire sounds like
nice that's relaxing
that's cool and that's to help
facilitate
um a lot of our users who are students
that are using it for Focus work time
yeah
nice okay cool that's good to get a
little a little insight into
what flipped
is like right there awesome
nice it's good to see
mindful Tech be developed like that
that's good stuff
now
interestingly enough
we're using technology to get away from
technology it's kind of funny
I look at it as using technology to help
with a habit okay and so we've managed
to do that with a lot of things like
um the way fitness trackers have helped
motivate certain behaviors
um Step counters and things like that
um and I see it in the same light as
we're trying to encourage people to
spend more minutes
away from their Tech so that's the unit
that we really care about is minutes
that's right so we've helped our user
base achieve over a billion minutes
spent away from their phones
and we are always trying to increase the
number of minutes that they're they're
spending doing things mindfully away
from their Tech
damn this is so interestingly nuanced so
it is because
I just came back from my fourth 10-day
vipassion of Meditation Retreat and when
I was there it was amazing to be away
from that device for 10 days sure it was
yeah at the same time it's cool because
when I come back to
the device it's cool to you know to
socialize and connect and and in real
time be able to talk to people through
that thing that are across the world and
learn the world's information at my
fingertips looking things up
um
which just yeah which just it's just
it's comp it's more complex than nuance
and we don't have a golden key for how
to solve the appendage of Technology yet
but I think you're on your way to being
one of the many players that's doing
research around the ethics research
around uh mindfulness research around
um the time that we're actually spending
on those devices versus it's not so I
like I like how I can just like click
through and uh set a habit a set of
intention which is for an hour or two or
three four hours do something and then
just you know put that away and then not
touch the device and
so that's six so there was an option for
like a 60 second break too so I can
always take a break so you could yeah
you you select the 60 second break and
then you can leave it and it wouldn't
end the session but then you have to
come back after the 60 seconds is done
yeah yeah yeah so again we do this in
relation to like fitness trackers is
when you stop when you're going for a
run you stop at a stoplight and you have
to stop your watch you have to remember
to turn it back on yeah yeah
and then there's no stop lights on the
hills in the nature
I'm from city city running I know I know
I've done both
um
okay and then how many people you said
are two years now you've been building
this how many people are using it
um so I'm about 75 000 monthly active
users 75 000. that's a lot that's
incredible good work good work and then
how many of those are premium users
um premium subscribers are about six
percent
of the users yeah and they get access to
um more customized features so they can
for example you can set flipped for a
specific amount of time uh like an hour
and 45 minutes if you want to have a
focus session that's outside of the
default moments that we've created
um there's also more sounds and there's
more statistics so you didn't check out
the the stat screen but there's more
comprehensive statistics if you pay for
it cool so you can see like all of your
stats for months past
um in a really nice graphic nice yeah
okay okay
hmm
and so what is the top
what's the top feature that is being
used
was the top session that's being
enabled study and self the study's an
hour yeah
um and
self is actually a
a tag you can just set so our users are
actually setting self sessions to track
just moments for themselves for
themselves also a self-session means
you're working on something about you
know yourself but
oh okay rather than something that's
like a paper or a project or yeah yeah
well it's all self-reported so we're
able to track
um if people change their tag and set it
as something and the most common ones
right now are study itself okay yeah
okay yeah
and what's the most popular so then I
guess
well I guess if if six percent are
premium then what is the cost
um it's 24 a year oh or six dollars a
month yeah yeah it's really affordable
yeah yeah yeah it's like two bucks a
month yeah yeah it's pretty pretty
affordable yeah
um
interesting and then
what how big is the team right now and
where are you based uh we're six people
we're based in Toronto in Toronto
yep nice
and what's the future afflict
our vision really is to be
um a digital Wellness Hub that has all
of your needs across what it is that is
Wellness for you
so right now I think that it's a little
bit too fragmented in that
you either have to meditate or you have
to listen to
um
sound that is helping you fall asleep
for example
um or
journaling all of these things are all
in seem to be very independent of one
another
um and for us is that people sort of
enter flipped as it's a very low
friction starting point where you enter
flipped and you're not actually really
intending to have a wellness experience
but
by that first intention of I want to
spend less time on technology is that
entry point into Wellness yeah and so we
want to have
um more resources which were which we're
actually creating Partnerships instead
of creating our own content we're
creating Partnerships with content
providers who will feature it within
flipped so soon that's going to be Aura
which um
yeah yeah we like them a lot
um not the ring all right no interest in
which Aura yeah meditation those
experiences yeah we like them a lot yeah
um so we're going to be featuring some
of their content in flipped
um oh that's cool yeah particularly
around
um helping with anxiety and stress for
students and young professionals
interesting so then you'll have video
content it's audio it's audio content
yeah and I'd like to enhance the the
audio therapy side as well so we have
sounds
um already but I'd like to I'd like to
improve that on that offering I think
there's a lot that can be done in the
audio therapy space
um
and then also connecting people to
Opportunities and events and things that
are happening around them that are um
in the wellness
Market yep
um so just being a one sort of a
One-Stop place where you can get
everything that you need mindfulness
related
yeah
and then
and then what are like some of the
statistics that you've been learning
about the use using technology I mean
you probably know at least some stats
about how the use using Tech because of
your experience is that what you hear
yeah
um well they're pretty addicted to their
technology yeah
um usage has increased over the last
couple of years so it's gone from a
couple of hours a day to about five to
six hours a day on your phone alone
um but what's really really interesting
and exciting for us is that this year
Deloitte did a global survey and
discovered that over half of 18 to 24
year olds are actually looking for ways
to disconnect from technology and that
they're very aware of this Behavior
that's great
um and even just in personal
conversations
in just one-on-ones we do interviews
with young people
um their awareness is very AI
um that's good yeah that's good so it's
so it's almost as though young people
even though sometimes we think that
they're not aware of them being
manipulated it seems as though a lot of
them are very aware of their use of
Technology yeah I think this is a bit of
an Insight that we have because a lot of
our users they come to us knowing that
they have an issue that they want to
solve or they want to improve upon a
behavior or achieve goals that they've
been unable to because of their
relationship with tech totally and
that's great when we get when we get
surveys like I did a 2000 user survey
recently and all like you know last
question is like anything else you want
to share and just all of the personal
stories that we were getting from users
about how flipped has helped them in a
variety of ways is really really
interesting to hear yeah
um what were some of those
um you know we would have some people
who say that they have like ADHD and how
and I you know it's not something that
is clinically recommended in any
capacity and that's very inspiring to
hear that um
these people who have have uh suffer
with with ADD and attention disorders
that they come to flipped and they find
a solution in that that is great yeah
yeah
um also people saying things like it it
helps them get through their thesis or
you know they wouldn't be able to sleep
without it I I think that's really
interesting that we've created something
that's versatile for a number of
different needs totally
um as simple as just getting off your
phone yeah
yeah
that's great that it's being used for so
many different
people across different use cases for
them that's awesome and then
um it also seems as though
I can't I guess I can't tell yet and
even like medically it seems as though
this needs to be
um more of an option for potentially a
physician that's diagnosed someone with
ADHD to prescribes like yo try flipped
you know our friends over at siempo who
we've had on the show as well yeah yeah
yeah like you know prescribe these see
what happens yeah there's also
um neuroscientists that have made video
games that help with focus and retaining
Focus for people with ADHD so you can
and they're they're going through
clinical trials even to yeah to be able
to actually have that be a prescription
this all this this is all very good that
these things coming together there's one
other thought that I had that I wanted
to share with you which was um
out of the you know out of the 18 to 24
year olds 50 of them want a better
relationship with their technology I
just I want to know what percentage of
them will actually do something though
and how easy it has to be for them to do
something what do they mean a better
relationship with their technology what
does that actually mean because
it can mean so many different things
yeah
I think I think perhaps it's
my feeling about it is that most people
who are now 18 have
grown up with nothing else and they're
feeling like that's not right
um they're sensing that there's
something missing in that experience
um yeah if someone were in 2018 they
by six years old there was Facebook
right so that's that generation they've
grown up with nothing else they know
nothing else their parents have been
using technology
um and I think it's impacted
relationships in a way that they can
recognize is is wrong
um you know things like eye contact and
and really important human behaviors are
being kind of messed with and
manipulated and
they're recognizing that this is a
problem
um whether or not they can do anything
about it
um is a really good question and I think
we've tapped into the the types of
people who are going out of their way to
find Solutions
um
which is why we have like a community
aspect where we're trying to get our
Champions and our our really power users
to create little micro communities where
they bring their friends and they're all
using flip together
um and so I think I think it's a matter
of changing
changing that social
um Norm that hey this is okay this is
what how it is this is what everyone
does to wait a second this is this isn't
good for me
um I know with it like deep within my
being that we need to find Connection in
deeper more meaningful ways
um and that's just like a very that's a
great human nature to tap into and I
think that's why there's that survey
result and I think that over the years
we're going to see more people
gravitating towards
um offline experiences and
low-tech experiences I'm already seeing
it in a lot of young people you know
Christian's younger brother my
co-founder's younger brother he was 13
when he got his first smartphone he's
he's 17 now
and he's like an old soul so
it's really really interesting I think
that
there will be sort of this Resurgence of
low-tech experiences
hmm
to think about the youth being
so
being born without the opportunity to
know what it's like to live without
technology it's kind of weird
stuff yeah they're the first generation
yeah to not know what it's like yeah
anyone born after the year 2000
basically yeah or even just a bit
earlier too yeah yeah
and it's a big evolutionary experiment
that we're going under everything is but
especially now a technology just seems
to
I frequently have conversations with
people about the Nuance of things
especially of of smartphones and social
media you can tell that I'm not
um
like there are reasons why when I got
into a group of you know like four
people
and that if we're all like okay let's
all use flipped right now and we turn it
off for four hours so we can actually
hang out without that
it's great I can see how that would be
fantastic
you know I can also see the potential of
a
missing a really important conversation
when someone was trying to call you or
being you shouldn't hang out with people
that you could get bored with but if you
do get bored for a period of time you
know being able to go and and and and do
something you know either go sit in the
grass since you're outside with your
friends or pick up your phone and do
something on your phone so there's it's
very strange anyway we could talk about
this for hours I'm sure you guys do talk
about this for long periods of time
well
in either of those cases you could still
use your phone even if you are using
flipped so
it would just Mark you as unsuccessful
yeah that's right just stop it just stop
it and start it again yeah yeah it's a
prac it's like a practice okay for your
yeah or your mind if you think about it
and I always I always go back to
um like a fitness tracking type
experience and comparing it to the way
that we address our physical health yeah
is that that's good if someone told you
to go for a run and you're like okay I'm
gonna go for a run
you could stop at any point you could
choose to end it you don't have to just
keep running
um but if you were like I'm gonna go for
an hour long run
and you gave up halfway through
that's that's that there's nothing wrong
with it
um
but you didn't meet your goal Maybe
and I think there's a lot
of that type of thing happening in in
meditation and wellness is it's trying
to turn
um these behaviors into more habitual
yeah more habitual behaviors
your app is really well designed
thank you it's a well-designed app it's
a very friendly design it is I like it a
lot
um yeah user experience is signed well
and then I like how you I like how you
said that it's about changing the habits
it's about moving in the direction of of
being more aware of our use of
Technology rather than being unaware of
our use of it so at least if flipped is
getting people to become more aware of
their use of technology that can overall
be said as being a good thing whether
you are being bored in that conversation
or missing that call or whatever well
and think about it imagine you and a
group of friends decide okay we're gonna
try to use flipped and just engage with
each other for the next two hours so you
all flip off your devices and then
you're Midway through your conversation
and someone says something that you want
to Google sure
you're going to reach for your phone and
flipped is going to be there that remind
that that moment of friction that makes
you go oh yes I'm flipped off right now
maybe I shouldn't be Googling this yeah
and let's keep talking that's right and
that's the experience that we managed to
get into classrooms because it forces
students to think twice about using
their phones when they are they're
engaged in a class
so that's part of the trajectory is to
get into classrooms we already we're in
over 100 Schools right now already in
the US and then does that mean the kids
all have to have flipped or what does
that mean it's we're in we're in
actually mostly University classes okay
um and it's up to the educator how they
introduce it
um but usually they tie some sort of
Engagement credit for if you use flipped
for 100 of your course
um so that's cool yeah yeah yeah so you
can gain some points if you do 100 of
course or not exactly 90 or 80 they get
to choose how to how to yep yeah most
actually most of them it's like if
you've used flips for 80 of class time
so that they're giving them a buffer
yeah exactly yeah
that's cool stuff 100 classrooms around
the US
um oh more than 100 we're at 100
different schools hundreds of more than
100 classes yeah yeah nice so that hits
like what 10 000 students Alone
um yeah we've we've uh had over 15 000
students great subscribe and
um 13 000 uh just regular
um consumers on the on just any any day
subscribers yeah
wow
this is awesome yeah thank you for
introducing me to this yeah Elena thank
you for coming onto the show I really
appreciate it pleasure thanks for having
me did we didn't miss anything that you
wanted to touch on do you think I think
it was pretty good
yeah yeah I think um
I think what's what's a an important
takeaway is that
um in all of life there should be uh
meaning and intention to your actions
and I think our relationship with
technology has really missed that Mark
totally
um so we are really trying to introduce
that into people's worlds and for young
people who've never known what that is I
think we are really you know helping
change their behavior by just adding an
ounce of intention
what they're doing I really like the way
of putting that it's just adding that
ounce of intention into relationships
with technology yeah that's that's
really good becoming more aware of the
habits reforming with the Technologies
yeah yeah that that I think everyone can
get behind yeah I'm always looking for
things like that that everyone can get
behind something like that yeah because
then it's not you're not you're not
we're not doing the binary like device
bad or device good but more like just
have a little bit more awareness and
intention before we use it we definitely
don't think that it's bad
um and we want to use technology to
enable that understanding
um and teach people to have a better
relationship with it yeah through it
being used yeah
everyone check out the link in the bio
for flipped definitely give them a go
give it a shot see how you like it yeah
um huge thank you for tuning in thanks
for coming on the show appreciate it and
give us a comment below we'd love to
hear your thoughts about how it's going
using the service or what your thoughts
are about thinking more towards our
habits with our devices and technology
and go and build the future go manifest
your dreams into the world much love
everyone and we will see you soon peace